la muerte de miles de peces alarma Irak
las autoridades del país encontraron a
los animales sin vida en el río alés en
el sur del territorio según los expertos
la causa podría ser la disminución del
agua por la sequía y la falta de lluvias
que afectan a la región después de la
muerte de varios peces en este canal
debido a la disminución de los niveles
de agua y la falta de descargas de agua
a través del área de alcahir Esto llevó
a la falta de espacio y de oxígeno entre
los peces y los organismos vivos
presentes en el río el calor también
causa estragos en Europa mientras se
prevén nuevas olas de calor en países
como España en Italia las temperaturas
ya se han vuelto sofocantes en Roma la
capital alcanzaron 36 grados centígrados
el fin de semana somos de Singapur Así
que el calor es algo a lo que estamos
acostumbradas Pero esto es una locura
nunca hemos tenido nada por encima de
los 32 grados de las altas temperaturas
a las lluvias en India las
precipitaciones azotaron la capital y
sus alrededores el domingo según el
departamento
meteorológico del país Nueva Delhi
registró 153 milímetros de lluvia ese
día la tercera cantidad más alta para
Julio en más de dos décadas nos
enfrentamos a muchos desafíos el agua a
veces llega al pecho a la cintura e
incluso si llueve un poco el área se
inunda mientras en Nueva York tormentas
inusuales afectan al país norteamericano
el estado reportó carreteras y casas
inundadas mientras que la policía emitió
una alerta de emergencia por inundación
repentina